hallo leute
Ich habe es geschafft tatsächlich mal am rechner zu sein
vor die ersten leute von euch da sind
Geht das sound und alles? ja. Moin erster ist da
hat ja nicht lang gedauert genau 37 sekunden
normalerweise mache ich den stream an
und
Gehe noch mal kurz ab für weiß ich drei vier minuten kann ich das mal live hier mit verfolgen
die leute in stream kommen
yes folks moin
tourtongue am start
das kann ich nicht aussprechen
und leute wie war euer tag heute? ihr musstet ja heute arbeiten vermutlich
ich nicht ich muss erst morgen wieder
Sollt ihr im stream geschafft?
Also wie ich mich kenne wahrscheinlich nix
und gerade dabei sind ich mache mal kurz meine vm schon mal an
Was heißt schon mal? Ich weiß gar nicht ob wir die brauchen
Und mach mal kurz package updates weil arch by the way
dein linkes auge kann 34 fps in fake news
glaube ich dir nicht
impossible
Überhaupt nicht viele updates heute
geht sich doch sehr entgrenzen
Homeoffice war schön lässig na dann
Ich werde morgen homeoffizieren
Und am mittwoch fahre ich da nach frankfurt warum fahre ich am mittwoch nach frankfurt ganz einfach
Weil jemand da ist mit dem ich all you can eat mittagessen gehen kann
Der einzige grund hat kein tieferen grund warum ich mittwochs nach frankfurt fahre
gibt es was besonderes zu futtern? ne und ich habe auch misserzählt
Es ist nicht wirklich all you can eat aber es ist es ist so viel dass ich eigentlich nie an die grenze gekommen bin bisher
Muss gerade mal was checken
Ich muss mal kurz in den terminkalender gucken dass ich nicht irgendwie verkackt habe dass ich da doch morgen hin muss
Also morgen lass mal gucken
Was habe ich denn? Leute ich kann euch mal kurz an meinem meeting an meinem
Es haben doch letztens leute gefragt so max warum so hoher mieten das war ein comments unter video ich glaube jetzt bringe ich
Durcheinander so max was ist da los so hoher meetinganteil und sowas das war nicht im stream das war unter
unter video ich lasse euch mal an einem terminkalender teilhaben
für die nächste woche
Und nächste woche kann ich sagen ist das gemiete nicht so schlimm wie die woche drauf aber ihr werdet gleich sehen es ist trotzdem ziemlich heftig
Lulle alfred dankeschön für den sub
Und mr. Amek pox subscription also pass mal auf
Morgen
Morgen geht's los 39 daily scrum
Der hätte hier bestimmt auch alle bock drauf damit schön dreidimensional diagonal skaliert das war schön agile ist
Dann gibt es team daily
Ja eins reicht natürlich nicht das ist ja klar dann gibt es hollow up pen test
Was auch immer da penetrated wird
Gut ich weiß es
sage ich jetzt aber nicht im
im stream
Dann habe ich auch oder wird es auch dann wird es auch
extrem agil wieder nachmittags
habe ich ein backlog refinement termin
Okay, leute ich gebe zu morgen ist gar nicht so viel gemiete morgen ist nur ungefähr
ungefähr 50 prozent ja sogar ein bisschen weniger 45 prozent der zeit gemiete
ab 40 prozent ich miete von 9.30 bis 10.30
dann miete ich von 10.30 bis 9.30 bis 11 und dann noch mal von 14.30 bis 16 uhr
Also ich habe zusammen 50 prozent des tages ist gemietet
Ich habe morgen also quasi zeit von 7 bis 9.30 was zu machen
und dann von
12 uhr 30 bis 14 uhr 30 immerhin immerhin kriege ich morgen von meinen acht stunden arbeitszeit vier stunden arbeit
Ist er auch schon mal was
So also das war mal mit das war mein tag morgen
Dann geht es weiter mittwoch
Lenkungsausschuss ich manche sache muss ich ein bisschen anonymisieren dass man das nicht so direkt zuordnen kann
Leute aber sinngemäß stimmt das was ich sage dann habe ich
lenkungsausschuss update
am mittwoch
Daily scrum logischerweise
Passt mal auf jetzt es hört nicht auf agil zu sein leute wir sind wir sind massive hyper agil ich habe als erstes
Lenkungskreis irgendwie updates dann habe ich daily scrum und dann habe ich jetzt haltet euch fest haltet euch fest
Agiler geht es kaum
weekly catch-up call
Also also nix nix tomatensauce
Sondern ketchup wie aufholen
Weekly catch-up call habe ich dann ja ja da wird eine halbe stunde aufgeholt
Weiß nicht wer ich das ausgedacht hat
Jetzt für jedes meeting so eine agenda vorher
naja
Nee, nee nicht bei allen aber einigen bei einigen ich würde sagen bei
30 prozent gibt es agenda
Okay, so dann wird geketchup
dann gibt es
Gruppen meeting dann gibt es team meeting und dann gibt es noch mal
Einen weiteren austausch sync termin fürs projekt mittags, okay, also mittwoch wird schon mal gar nix gemacht
Mit mittwoch mittwoch geht es los ich habe es nicht
9 uhr geht es los
lenkungskreis update und dann mehr oder weniger
durchgemiete bis 16 uhr
Okay, das war mittwoch also leute also ich habe quasi in dieser woche dann
Zumindest an zwei tagen insgesamt drei bis vier stunden was machen können
So dann geht es weiter es wird bestimmt noch besser lasst mal kurz gucken donnerstag daily scrum logischerweise
Das könnte man gar nicht agil sein daily scrum daily team meeting
Service vorstellung für irgendwas
Weiteren termin den ich euch jetzt nicht vorlesen kann weil das zu offensichtlich ist und was es geht
Einen gibt es einen kubernetes schuhe fix
So und dann sind wir schon beim freitag daily scrum daily team und dann habe ich moment
Moment
Moment das funktioniert nicht
Am freitag okay passt mal auf jetzt wird jetzt wird es lustig also freitag habe ich geht geht easy los wie immer daily scrum
Und danach kommt team daily so aber jetzt achtung achtung
Ich habe dann zusätzlich noch
von 9 45
bis 17 uhr
Wobei so lange bleibe ich nicht da 16 uhr schluss aber spätestens in 9 45 bis 17 uhr
testing infrastruktur
und parallel dazu habe ich noch
Andere einladung
Dann bin ich mal gespannt wie das am freitag läuft
Ich glaube ich werde es mir ich glaube ich werde es mir am freitag echt einfach machen ja keck business ja ich werde es ich werde es
mir am freitag echt einfach machen und zwar
Ich werde mich einfach ab 9 45
in das grundlegende
infrastruktur in das testing infrastruktur
Meeting setzen
Und
Dann ist man rot in teams
und den restlichen tag
Einfach zu keinem anderen meeting mehr gehen und vielleicht in der zwischenzeit wo ich nichts testen muss
Irgendwas sinnvolles machen wie viel tommy danke für den sub ja so sieht es aus
Mich hat auch heute jemand angeschrieben von vom projektmanagement so max dir ist doch klar dass du als testing lead eingetragen bist am freitag
Also
Was soll ich testen
Ich habe extra letzte woche in unsere die haben so eine excel tabelle gebaut wo alle leute drinnen stehen die was testen müssen
Ich habe da letzte woche extra noch reingeguckt da war mein name nicht einmal drin
Aber angeblich bin ich testing lead jetzt ich weiß nicht woher
Okay, dann will ich mal die sachen beantworten die jetzt hier aufgeschlagen sind war das heute ein zweiter arbeitstag
Also am freitag angefangen stimmt du hast am freitag angefangen ja
letzte woche
Weil er der erste war okay das ist auch ein dummer anfangstag der frei wobei eigentlich nicht ohne scheiß leute freitag ist ein super
Ist ein super ein einstiegstag weil da bist du den ersten tag total überfahren und kannst erst mal zwei tage pause machen
Eigentlich eigentlich ist ziemlich gut ja
Ja stimmt stimmt jetzt wenn ich mir das mal so genau überlesen genau überlege und falls ich mir die subs überlegen überlesen habe dann
Sorry, ich gucke gleich noch mal nach
Wo war brain macht das nicht so mit
Hey max ich will im september lass mich mal kurz lass mich mal kurz
Subscriptions checken sonst vergesse ich wieder die hälfte
Bei wehleute ich habe gehört das ist 4.9. da sind bestimmt wieder viele prime subs frei geworden
Beefy tommy, mr. Alfred subscription danke leute das war es habe ich nicht habe ich nichts übersehen
so
Hey max
ich will im september
2024 eine fachinformatiker das wäre doch eigentlich
Als muss ich mal als thema okay
Hey max ich will im september 2024 eine fachinformatiker ausbildung machen
allerdings frage ich mich was ich
Moment allerdings frage ich mich was mache ich nach der ausbildung jedes
Weiß ich auch nicht wo soll ich das wissen
Es gibt ja keine konkrete job bezeichnung naja doch es sucht zwar kaum einer nach
fachinformatiker system integration danach genau du machst
Devsec bis win sec ops machst du du kannst zum beispiel zum beispiel bei steps
auf step stone gehen und mal nach den üblichen verdächtigen suchen
Software entweder du suchst nach syphops engineer du suchst nach systemadministrator
Du suchst nach keiner irgendwas mit cloud
Da kannst du dich mal ein bisschen umgucken was es so gibt
Weil nach fachinformatiker selbst sucht kaum einer und wenn dann ist es irgendein billigen support kram
Da musst du dich mal ein bisschen umgucken
allerdings wenn du
in einem jahr erst startest
Dann mach dir jetzt mal nicht so viele gedanken darum du wirst während einer ausbildung schon
Die passenden buzzwords lernen nach was du suchen musst und du wirst eigentlich mehr oder weniger gut wissen nach der ausbildung
Was du so für stellen die angucken kannst danach also
Da würde ich mir jetzt nicht so viele gedanken machen ehrlich gesagt
Ja automatisch das deployed wird wenn es kaputt geht wenn keiner mehr da ist es ist immer die beste zeit
Wenn du was mit linux machen willst kannst du auch linux engineer suchen oder so dass das was ich gerade mache
Aber titel sind also was heißt titel job bezeichnung ist egal
Kannst alles mögliche unter allen möglichen job bezeichnungen finden das ist alles so variabel
Oh nice, ich sehe erst das ausbildungsgehalt schon mal verschenkt hier
Erstes vorgezogenes ausbildungsgehalt
Danke für die ganzen subs
Tommy danke für die ganzen subs
Wir hatten glück gehabt captain poggers hat wieder eins gekriegt nice der hat es auf jeden fall vom hat er eigentlich keins mehr gerade
Der hat es auf jeden fall der hat es auf jeden fall verdient
Sonst hätte ich das gesehen hätte ich ihm auch eins gegiftet
Coke zero day
Das sag ich sag ich auch am start die mottges haben aber heute richtig glück oder dass die alle was abgreifen an subscriptions finde ich nice
strikeout und blackbird
Bei blackbird muss ich immer an muss ich an was ähnliches denken
Falls falls noch irgendjemand
Blackbird killstick aus black ops 1 kennt nick bnx danke für den sub
okay
Captain poggers wenn es sich leistet nächstes mal giftig die ein
so
Was du danach machen kannst nach der ausbildung meetings richtig korrekt
In wie viel damit in keinem da kommen tatsächlich immer leute
Ich habe das teilweise auch gemacht also ein ein tipp kann ich euch geben leute wenn ihr wenn ihr
Nicht genervt werden wollt von irgendwelchen meeting einladung blockt euch ab 15 Uhr 30
Ich habe ich habe geblockt bei mir im kalender ab 15 Uhr 30 bis morgens um 7 Uhr
Dass mich keiner zu irgendwelchen komplett unchristlichen zeiten mehr einlädt
Unchristliche zeiten das ist auch so eine redewendung von meinem opa irgendwie
Mit redewendung muss man ein bisschen aufpassen da hat sich einiges da hat sich einiges gewandelt die letzten jahre
Und nicht nur die letzten jahre manche sachen sind einfach zu ja boomer negativ vorbehaftet
Was ist denn der unterschied daily team meeting und daily scrum das kann ich dir erklären ist ganz einfach chat
Ist das doch das doch ob obviously was der unterschied ist oder
Im einen wird agil skaliert und im anderen nicht so eigentlich logisch
Also aber ernsthaft ich kann es dir erzählen der unterschied ist daily scrum gehört zum projekt in dem ich mitarbeite
Und daily team meeting ist mit den leuten aus meinem team nicht mit den projekt leuten
Richtig ja ja coke zero day hat es schon wieder gecheckt
Aber ist ja auch klar hat ja direkt iq boost bekommen durch den durch den gifted sub
Welche lieder solltest du moment was was ach so
Nein ich jetzt habe ich verstanden
Nein, nein die haben mir geschrieben ich bin test lead
Also ich soll derjenige sein der die testsonder irgendwie für infrastruktur durchführen ich weiß gar nicht was ich eigentlich testen soll
IT berufe podcast ist das denn
Erst mal times new roman beste schriftart schon mal
Den kenn ich nicht
habe ich noch nicht gesehen die seite
Ja
Finde ich finde ich ist eine gute sache ja
Ja, aber du musst auch nicht zu allem sagen ich übernehme das
Fachinformatiker.de gründer ach der ist das aha wusste ich nicht
Wusste gar nicht dass es einen gründer in dem sinn hat aber klar irgendjemand muss in die seite mal registriert haben und aufgemacht haben
die daten die
Ich wollte ernsthaft haben die datenbank
Die bahn
Sucht noch viel sie ist auch als job titel ja gut bei der bahn wundert mich ja nix mehr
Im moment bin ich gelernter hotelfachmann will raus möchte entgehen und da bin ich aufs ist ja
Aber wenn du 2024 startest wahrscheinlich so in dem dreh wie jetzt
So september 2000 das ja noch wirklich lange hin
Ich meine du kannst dich du kannst sicherlich dich ein bisschen darauf vorbereiten je nachdem was das für eine firma ist wenn du schon
Ungefähr weißt was die so machen
Schadet sich nichts die ein oder anderen sachen basics anzugucken aber ganz ehrlich als azubi ist es jetzt nicht so
Als müsstest du alles schon können manche denken das stellen dann vielleicht auch in der ausbildung fest es ist nicht so
So ein bisschen basics sich angucken ist nicht verkehrt wenn sie jetzt ein jahr langweilig ist ansonsten
Gammeln noch ein jahr rum und dann geht es nächstes jahr los
Also rumgammeln wirst wahrscheinlich eh nicht machen weil du aktuell ja noch in deinem alten beruf arbeitest
Warum bist du der meinung kubernetes nicht selber zuhause beziehungsweise in den meisten fällen dass es nicht sinnvoll ist weil die meisten leute nicht wissen
was sie machen
Und ich würde mir auch noch nicht anmaßen komplett bei allem zu wissen was ich mache
kubernetes ist tatsächlich nicht so easy mal als beispiel nur mal nur mal ein beispiel
Damit man damit ich das bisschen besser verdeutlichen kann was ich meine also
Kann ich da vielleicht sogar hier was zeigen
So man kann in kubernetes einen service anlegen
das
Uniformierung so und da gibt es verschiedene typen
kann man sagen type
Und als type gibt es service type als type gibt es cluster ip
Note port load balancer und external name external name können wir streichen das ist ein dns alias ist es wurscht
Cluster ip und note port sind in dem fall auch nicht so wirklich relevant weil die funktionieren aber wenn du sagst typ load balancer
Dann wirst du ein problem haben wenn du das selbst hostest und dich wunderst warum typ load balancer nicht geht
Warum geht typ load balancer nicht weil typ load balancer zwar festgelegt ist in dieser
Jammel spezifikation also der kubernetes cluster frisst das aber das brauche
Infrastruktur unterstützung und diese infrastruktur schützen hast hast du erst mal nicht also das wird bei dir lokal schlicht und ergreifend nicht funktionieren
Damit das lokal funktioniert brauchst du dann sowas wie
metal lb zum beispiel
habe ich hier schon aufgemacht
Damit kannst du dann
Diesen typ erst verwenden und du kommst dabei ganz vielen stellen ganz vielen punkten vom hundertste ins tausendste
Und bei jedem neuen punkt hast du erst mal keine ahnung davon wie man das ordentlich macht
Weil am ende hast du dann in den cluster
Den du laufen neu aufbauen musst weil die irgendwas verkackt hast und das ist jetzt auch nicht für die abteilung der anwendung sonderlich zu
zuträglich
hat das ist zum beispiel ein beispiel für
Und dazu kommt
dass es auf den ersten blick
Gar nicht so kompliziert aussieht also kubernetes hat so eine richtig so eine so eine finde ich ganz lustige lernkurve
Aber jetzt hier paint paint magic
Die lernkurve von kubernetes sieht ungefähr so aus
Du denkst erst mal du denkst erst mal alter ist es komplex
So dann machst du dann beschäftigt sich mal eine woche mit
Dann beschäftigt sie dich eine woche mit und denkst da hast du dann nach einer woche hast du so die basic typen drin
Du weißt wie man den service anlegt du weißt was für servicetypen es gibt du weißt wie man deployments anlegt und solche geschichten halt ja
Das weißt du dann und dann denkst du dir so als du das angeguckt hast
Eigentlich ist das doch gar kein ding ist doch eigentlich relativ übersichtlich
Dann geht das dann geht das erst mal so und du denkst okay so wild so wild ist es nicht so aber dann geht's los
Wenn du dann wirklich anfangen willst damit was zu machen wenn du nicht einfach nur trocken übermacht denkst ich hab's verstanden und dann kommst
Du hierhin so nach dem motto alter warum geht das mit meinem load balancer nicht warum funktioniert deswegen mein ingress nicht richtig und warum?
Warum kriege ich meine ressourcen nicht gescheit wieder entfernt und
Wie kann ich überhaupt storage richtig anbinden und warum hat das ding keine gescheiten storage classes von haus aus die sinnvoll sind weil das braucht
Übrigens auch oh wunder cloud infrastruktursupport
Und dann wirst du irgendwann feststellen oh mist ja ich kenne jetzt zwar die ganzen ganzen basics drumherum aber
Allein schon die load balancer ist nicht so gut und dann bist du dann auch nicht so gut
Mit den ganzen basics drumherum aber allein schon die basics anzuwenden dann dann wird es schon so
Ordentlich anzuwenden gerade halt auch selbst vieles rausführen und dann wirst du irgendwann feststellen da hast du irgendwie die wand dann wirst du
feststellen oh mist
Mit kubernetes alleine ist es ja noch gar nicht getan ich muss mich dann mit metal db beschäftigen
Ich muss mich dann mit flux oder argo cd oder irgendwie sowas beschäftigen ich muss vielleicht auch mal gucken okay wie können wir dann ordentlich
Images dafür erstellen weil weil irgendwie haben wir ja aktuell sowas noch gar nicht wie kann ich denn gucken ob meine images nicht
Irgendwelche outdated libraries verwenden und so da kommst du vom hundertsten ins tausendste und irgendwann guckst du dann mal hier
Wie heißt die cnf cloud native computing foundation
Landscape sondern da landest du dann irgendwann hier
Und dann wirst du feststellen
people said
Ich muss ja gefühlt um ordentlichen cluster zu betreiben
30 prozent von diesem ganzen mist können
Und dann dann dann dann hittest du hier erst mal die erste wand und denkst dir will ich das wirklich alles selber machen
Und die meisten sagen an dem punkt nee ich nehme einfach irgendwas manage das und gut ist
Die nächsten sagen ah wir wollen es aber selber machen da kommt dann sowas wie
Hat mich nicht vor wie heißt das tanzu oder tenzu oder sowas im spiel wo man das zwar selbst betreiben kann aber irgendwie noch ein
bisschen
Ich habe das selbst noch nie benutzt keine ahnung ich
Wo man wo man zwar selbst betreiben kann aber es trotzdem viel für einen schon automatisch geregelt wird was das meme
Jus cubanetes
expectations reality
Ja das trifft das trifft tatsächlich ganz gut ja
So und dann
Wo hatte ich denn jetzt das bild von da hier sondern wirst du feststellen meine güte gibt es da gibt es da viel shit also
Allein schon allein schon wenn man hier reinguckt oder das ist ja gut
Alles jetzt so spannend wir sortieren das mal nach projekt typ dass das nun dass es nur die offiziellen cloud cloud native
Projekte sind dann wirst du fest ok da gibt es aber trotzdem immer noch ganz schön viele und ehrlich gesagt leute wenn ich mir das gerade so
anguck
Die hälfte kenne ich auch nicht ja
Übrigens der landscape geht hier noch weiter nach rechts also man müsste den landscape ungefähr so klein machen dass man da noch was erkennt ja
Ja stimmt du brauchst ein container registry die du noch betreiben willst
Betreiben musst irgendwo musst du deine images hosten vielleicht willst du dich mit service meshes beschäftigen linker die ist ja was auch immer
Filesystems storage für kubernetes das gibt es noch dachte das doch das gibt es gar nicht mehr
Dann willst du dich mit deployments beschäftigen wie kriege ich was drauf auf meine kisten also
Es ist
Ungefähr so wie ich das gemalt habe
Ich sage nicht dass man das nicht selbst betreiben kann ich meine cloud anbieter machen das ja auch und wenn du ganz super spezielle anfangs
Und irgendwas mag das durchaus sinn machen aber ich finde das beste beispiel ist schon mal zu sagen hey
Stell mal typ lautbalancer einstelle fest das geht nicht was brauche ich denn dafür und da brauchst du ein party produkt und dann
Das nimmt kein ende mehr
Das wie schätzt du das verhältnis von tolle kollegen zu gehalt ein du meinst
Ab wie viel das eine das andere aufwiegt oder wie
Ja also das ist schwer zu sagen
Das ist schwer zu sagen das kommt immer auf den das kommt immer auf den schwere grad an
Und negativ wiegt oftmal schwerer als positiv also wenn du zum beispiel leute hast
die dich extrem abfacken
Dann müssten die die dir quasi extrem abfacken
Die dich extrem abfacken
Dann müssten die die dir quasi extrem unrealistisch viel gehalt bezahlen dass du dich wohlfühlen würdest
so und
Wenn du wenn du leute hast die nett sind
Dann ist es aber nicht so dass du sagen würdest okay ich verzichte auf 50 prozent des gehalts also
Am besten ist natürlich was wo du beides hast leute mit denen du ganz gut auskommst ich meine du musst jetzt
Ich weiß ja nicht was du unter tolle kollegen verstehst also mir reicht schon wenn ich mit allen ganz gut auskomme ich muss mit
Denen nicht beste beste freunde werden oder so weil es ist nice wenn man sich ganz gut verstehen ein bisschen so drumherum ein bisschen
Schwätzen kann oder so aber ich muss mit den meisten leuten jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen wir mal mich am wochenende treffen oder so
Wobei ganz ehrlich sind schon echt paar nette leute dabei
Aber ich will einfach meine ruhe haben
Also ich finde es ist beides wichtig und ein
Attraktiver arbeitsplatz den du auch haben möchtest beziehungsweise der halt
Auch besetzt werden kann weil der arbeitgeber ordentliche leute findet
Der muss ja der muss letztendlich alle drei sachen haben der muss ein ordentliches gehalt haben der muss ordentliche
Ja ordentliches das muss ordentliches unternehmen sein mit gutem gutem arbeitsklima
Ordentlichen ordentlichen umgang miteinander und
Umgänglichen leuten und halt auch den ein oder anderen vorteil die man dort vielleicht hat sei es jetzt irgendwie wenn man wenn man
Kinder hat den kindergarten oder irgendwie sowas oder irgendwelche anderen sachen die halt das genau erfüllen was man was man sich wünscht
Und
Ich weiß gar nicht ob man das so extrem sagen kann das ein oder das andere
Manchen ist es auch wichtig dass der laden morgen nicht pleite ist und sowas
Hätte ich mal diese liste aufgehoben leute wisst ihr wo ich die habe ich habe doch irgendwie ich habe ich hätte jetzt schon ein
Paar mal gebraucht ich habe doch irgendwann mal so eine liste gemacht
Ich habe doch irgendwann mal so eine liste gemacht
Was mir wichtig ist
Was mir wichtig ist bei einem arbeitsplatz
Habe ich das in der alten vm noch gemacht vielleicht das fand ich eigentlich ganz gut stream mir den
Was ist das?
Weil ich traue mich da nicht rein zu gucken ich muss euch mal kurz ausmachen ich will jetzt wissen was
Ich will ich will jetzt wissen was 0 txt ist ach das war auf irgendeinem test feil feilscher gerade
Das gibt es überhaupt nicht mehr
Das gibt es überhaupt nicht mehr okay ich habe nichts gesagt
Da die bass collection ja ja dann weiß ich dann weiß ich wirklich nicht wo ich das gemacht habe
weil
Ich hätte das jetzt schon ein paar mal brauchen können
Erst mal windows iso am start
Skills ne dann weiß ich nicht wo ich das hin habe vielleicht chat vielleicht wisst ihr es ich weiß es nicht
Das wäre jetzt ganz praktisch gewesen ja aber manchen ist das natürlich wichtig
Dass das unternehmen morgen noch da ist ich will nicht sagen dass mir das unwichtig ist
Wünschen studio code offen
Einfach das naming ist zu feil fährt ja also ich will nicht sagen dass mir das unwichtig jetzt ich fände es auch blöd wenn es
Das die firma morgen nicht mehr gibt oder so ja und wir dann alle vor der tür sitzen aber sicherheit ist jetzt nichts eines meiner
absoluten top prioritäten
Haben wir das denn haben wir das hier in wischl studio code gemacht oder
Ich glaube ich habe das unter windows in notepad gemacht wenn ich jetzt
Wenn ich es auch richtig in erinnerung habe
Ich habe bei einst auf keine ahnung die chat gpt antwort auf eine stellenanzeige
Dann weiß ich nicht mehr wo ich das hin habe massive graph
Das wäre jetzt ganz praktisch gewesen hätte ich das gefunden das ist der aktuelle zeitgeist was soll ich dazu sagen
Ich fände ich fände es auch ganz sinnig wenn man schon anhand des titels genau erkennen könnte
Was da eigentlich besprochen werden soll aber
Es ist halt dass er der zeitgeist dass das dann schon fix follow up call catch up call
Daily xy was auch immer heißt ja dankeschön für den sub
Leute ich habe eine idee wir können mal ins archiv gucken
Was was standen denn wir haben doch ein transkript für jeden stream
Was stand denn da alles drinne ich glaube da schon arbeitsplatz sicherheit oder so drinne
Relevanz nach datum der golo das ist alles nicht
Es ist schon
Hat er ein neues das habe ich sogar aufgemacht
Interessiert mich jetzt wo habe ich den krempel denn so meetings benennen
Das ist tiktok
Okay, ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich
Wenn ich sicher ob ich ein tiktok video aufmachen soll
Ach nee leute ich finde ich finde das jetzt nicht
zukunft
Sicher war das vielleicht ach keine ahnung
Da habe ich mir noch gar keine gedanken drüber gemacht wie viel ramm das menschliche auge hat was was denkt ihr chat wie viel ramm hat das
Beziehungsweise wie viel video memory du fängst im november als open shift admin an damit hatte ich noch nie was zu tun
Ja, wie gesagt das sieht auf den ersten punkt easy aus
Machst du damit was auf der arbeit
Ich kann dazu gar nichts sagen zu tanzu
Ich ich kenne das vom namen her ich weiß dass das von vm ist ich ich ich bilde mir auch ein dass das quasi so eine
kubernetes
compatible
Drüber ziehschicht für esx ist ich weiß es aber nicht genau ehrlich gesagt
Wie war das bei dir nach der ausbildung hast du dir geht nein habe ich nicht gedacht damals als ich damit angefangen habe gab es
das wort noch gar nicht
Ich habe auch keine fortbildung gemacht
Also bei mir gab es das wort noch gar nicht wo ich damit angefangen habe
Wir haben wir waren eine der ersten die mit server automatisierung angefangen haben und mit server automatisierung
Auch in gett gepflegt ganz ganz am anfang war es noch svn können euch das vorstellen
Und manche manche leute haben damals noch mit cf engine
Hat jemand mal die ehre gehabt mit cf engine was zu machen rum
experimentiert
Und ich habe das mit entwickelt
Entwickelt ist das falsche wort mit etabliert in der alten firma wo ich gearbeitet habe das server automatisch aufgebaut werden und monatlich neue
updates
packages und
konfig sachen bekommen über einen konfigurations management
Und ich habe das dann im endeffekt auch ja sie macht neun jahre gemacht
Insgesamt war ich länger bei dem laden aber ich habe das ja nicht die ganze zeit gemacht
Damals damals hat noch keiner an das wort der forbes gedacht und agile war auch noch nix
Ja ist doch gut ich finde es auch gut wenn man mehrere sachen macht
Ich fände ich fände es nice wenn ich auf der neuen arbeit auch ein bisschen interne tools entwickeln kann und ein bisschen mehr
skripten und so bin ich sofort dabei
war ich ja eh gern
Ja das ist richtig
Manche leute sehen aber auch auf den ersten blick nur so aus als hält man sie nicht aus
Manche sind dann nach etwas
Eingewöhnungsphase gar nicht mehr so wild
Also ich hatte schon leute man sagt ja mal der erste eindruck zählt aber ich hatte schon leute da habe ich gerade
Alter boy mit denen hältst du das nicht lange aus aber das ging dann auch
okay leute
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich mir trauen kann ein tiktok video aufzumachen
ein tiktok video von campus tüte
tiktok ist immer so eine sache für sich man weiß nicht was einen da erwartet
Okay, ich wage es jetzt einfach mal tiktok aufzumachen
Wait a minute was ist da gerade alles auf mich eingebrasselt
Was ist da gerade alles auf mich eingebrasselt ich muss es mal kurz öffnen ohne sound
alter die seite
Close alles ablehnen
Da weiß der hier neben schon gleich was
Tiktok ja hier neben mir schon gleich was los ist
okay
Poff du siehst den terminkalender deines gen z kollegen
Okay jetzt wird es gleich hyper cringe wahrscheinlich okay und weiter
Erholung vom social media meeting
durch tiktok
Das ist halt auch einfach fake
aber gut
Alter was jetzt mal seriously was empfiehlt mit tiktok denn da
Die sind doch noch nicht mal alle 18
Leute ich bin fast 40
Was ist da los
Da ist direkt
erreicht die da kommt die feuerwehr klein noch
Was hat mich exposed ja wie man gesehen hat am anfang scheine ich ja auch sehr oft auf tiktok zu sein
Heute also
Das ist eine gute idee ein bit
Hocke
Svn hat man alte arbeit gebe immer noch ich gehe mal davon aus ist ja nicht der einzige
Also bei meinem alten ist svm svn mittlerweile komplett weg bei meinem neuen habe ich svn bis jetzt auch noch nicht gesehen
Da ist glaube ich auch
unternehmensweit shit angesagt
und shit repos
monkaS
Es klickte gerade seltsam zweimal in im zimmer ich drehe mich um und da sitzt ein gras super so groß wie ein feuerzeug
Da würde ich da würde ich auch nee sorry falsch
Da würde ich auch den hier kriegen
Wobei gras hüpfer durchaus noch noch händelbar sind
Das das ist ein wort das verstehe ich nicht
Soll es franz heißen
konnten ja hornissen sind ja nicht so geil in der wohnung
Okay, so wir haben noch eine stunde zeit lasst uns doch mal irgendein ordentliches lassen wir ein zwei ordentliche videos zusammen angucken
Was hast du da eigentlich gemacht mit den drei hornissen hast du die eingefangen oder hast du die blatt gehauen
Bei so großen viechern tue ich mir immer ein bisschen schwer die platt zu hauen weil
Die machen so große flecken
Die muss man eigentlich ordentlich einfangen
Ich meine am einfachsten ist du kannst kurz das fenster aufmachen aber ich habe ja fliegengitter die kommen nicht wieder raus
kekalu
Was das was was kekalu
Db schnüffeln navigator am tag zu spitzenzeiten
Ich glaube das ist mir eine runde zu viel kekalu heute
Wobei das ja meistens durchaus fundiert ist was die was die dort
an talks halten
Aber aber das wird zu viel kekalu gerade
Denn es wird es ist leute es wird glaube ich zeit für den navigator champ
Ich habe wisst ihr was
Wisst ihr was ich habe zum fiecher einfangen ich habe mir bei amazon sowas hier gekauft
Spinnenfänger
ne
Sowas hier in der richtung sieht aber ein bisschen anders aus so was hier
Da kann man das ist so eine art besen so eine art besen
Das hat weiche haare dass man die nicht zerdrückt
Und wenn die fiecher groß genug sind kann man die damit mit diesen besen haaren einfangen und aber meiner sieht nicht so billig aus da
Sieht ein bisschen
advance da und stabiler aus als dieses teil
Und dann macht man zack und dann kann man die rausschmeißen
So viel geld ja 16 99 definitiv hat am
am limit
Hanau geliebt und nein leute so viel zum thema hanau geliebt ich muss euch was zeigen
Massive muss ich euch zeigen massiv
Extrem massiv
Wenn damit nicht
Bauchumfang oder so sondern guckt mal hier heute
neuer rekord
Schaut euch das mal an hanau liegt bei der way ich bin ich bin heute morgen gerannt
8 Uhr 19 bin ich geflitzt
6,1 kilometer ich habe heute wirklich gas gegeben da sieht man auch hier an dem pulse ja
Sieht man auch am puls
100 162 puls im durchschnitt zwar zwischenzeitlich sogar eine ganze ecke unter 40 minuten
6 minuten 31 pro kilometer
Und der schnellste der schnellste kilometer
Also ich war am anfang ein bisschen schneller ich habe ich habe es ein bisschen übertrieben als zum schluss
aber
ich habe fünf kilometer fast
unter 30 minuten gepackt
Gibt es den friseur eigentlich noch ja
Ich habe die fünf kilometer fast unter 30 minuten geschafft ich hatte mein zeige ich euch ich hatte
6 18 6 36
6 38 6 33 6 33 so und
In meinen rekorden hat es heute gesagt ich habe 32 irgendwie 32
30 minuten gebraucht für fünf kilometer also mein ziel mein ziel erst mal kurzfristig oder mittelfristig ist es
dass ich mal zehn kilometer unter 60 minuten packe
ich denke ich denke das ist durchaus
machbar
wenn ich jetzt irgendwie so 32 minuten für fünf kilometer habe und irgendwie 40 für
6,1 ich denke das geht jetzt vielleicht nicht heute und nicht morgen
Aber zumindest zumindest in nächster zeit ja so
macht spaß oder ist es eine qualität macht spaß aber es ist wirklich anstrengend gewesen also heute habe ich auch wirklich gas gegeben
ich hätte noch ein bisschen gekonnt so ist das nicht und ich hätte auch ich hätte auch noch ein bisschen schneller laufen können
aber ich meine ich wollte ja die sechs kilometer packen
und ich wollte daheim noch in
verfassung seinen restlichen tag irgendwas zu machen
Was was ich jetzt was ich echt mal machen müsste ist ich müsste auf den sportplatz gehen
und man wirklich und am besten noch jemand mitnehmen
und man wirklich dort eins zwei runden auf der bahn laufen und dann mal richtig vollgas geben und gucken was ich für eine maximale
maximale herz
für maximalen puls hab
also das höchste das höchste was ich jemals hatte
Ich habe eine smart was meinst was meinst was meinst du denn wie ich das aufgezeichnet habe heute wenn ich nicht eine smartwatch hätte
Weil ich habe gezählt ich habe mir den puls gemessen selbst beim rennen oder wie
das ist schon das ist alles schon
mit mit einer smartwatch aufgezeichnet
Kannst du deinen empfehlen also ich finde die finde die sehr nice preisleistungsmäßig auch vollkommen okay
also ich habe ich habe eine garmin forerunner
255 s kann das sein ich muss noch kurz hinten drauf gucken
Ja so was so eine hier habe ich die gibt es die gibt es
Mit und ohne musik ich habe sie ohne ich habe sie ohne musik
Da ist ein bisschen billiger ich habe die ohne musik ich klicke das mal an vielleicht kann man das auch ohne musik kaufen
Die ist mit musik ich ich habe die ohne musik
Die bisschen günstigere tut es auch voll und ganz ja bisschen günstig ist gut 200 euro
Kauft also ich habe die ohne musik
also musik heißt du kannst glaube ich über
bluetooth dann denn dann musik von hören leute kann ich verstehen dass es manche leute gerne machen aber ich habe immer ein handy immer dabei
so aber so viel habe ich nicht bezahlt ich kann es ich kann es nicht sagen warte mal ich gucke mal kurz bei amazon
Also die die billigere tut es auch investiert es auch ja
Nee nee die ist nicht so groß die sieht riesig groß aus die ist nicht so groß
Die ist die ist sogar
Also ich würde nicht sagen klein
Aber die ist nicht größer als mein arm an dem sie dran hängt also nicht breiter als der arm
Die geht die geht wie viel millimeter weiß ich hier steht keine ahnung
Keine ahnung das muss man muss man es darauf verlassen was da steht also
Ja und das rennen mache ich seit ungefähr einem monat weil am 2. am 2. august habe ich mir die uhr gekauft
Ich habe bezahlt lasst mal gucken order details
Ich habe bezahlt
289 euro
Ich glaube man muss
basic suchen
Kann es sein dass es die gerade bei amazon nicht mehr gibt ja anscheinend
Ja also ich habe wie gesagt ich habe ich habe 200
289 euro für bezahlt ich glaube das ist okay
Und ja das müsste ich echt mal machen
Ich glaube die ist noch nicht outdated die nächsten kommen erst nächstes jahr ist auch wurscht so
also
Das wollte ich jetzt sagen also was ich echt mal machen müsste ist ich müsste auf so einen sportplatz gehen da irgendwie ein zwei runden
Irgendwie ein zwei kilometer laufen da wirklich mal gucken was für maximal puls habe also das höchste was ich bisher gemessen habe
Mit der uhr war 184
184 185 184 war glaube ich das höchste
Aber ich hätte noch gekonnt
Ich bin aber nicht komplett bis zum umfallen gerannt
Weil ich danach noch vier kilometer heimlaufen musste
Deswegen habe ich gedacht lasst es mal bleiben ja
Und ich müsste echt mal ich müsste echt mal auf den sportplatz gehen
Ein bisschen mich einlaufen und dann volle pulle 1 2 kilometer durch flitzen und gucken was ich für eine maximale herzfrequenz
habe
Wohnort liegt und nein war ja auch nicht bekannt dass ich hanau und umgebung wohne beziehungsweise frankfurt und umgebung
Das wird mich nämlich echt mal interessieren weil dann könnte ich nämlich auch die pulsbereiche in der app richtig einstellen also
Wahrscheinlich ich vermute mal dass ich irgendwie so einen maximalen
Behalter also wie gesagt 184 war das höchste was ich bisher auf der uhr hatte aber das konnte ich auch nicht bis bis komplett zum limit
rennen weil
Ich halt noch vier kilometer heimlaufen musste also ich denke mal so was weiß ich
192 oder so irgendwie in dem dreh dann bin ich aber kurz vor umfallen
Das ist richtig ich habe auch tatsächlich schon überlegt ob ich ein brustgurt brustgurt brustgurt
holen soll
Zumindest werde ich das werde ich das demnächst mal machen und dann gucken ich meine ich bin fast 40 so faustformel sagt man ja
220 minus lebensjahre
Das wäre dabei das halt wirklich ungenau ist und an dem jeweiligen
Typ mensch komplett vorbei sein kann das wäre wäre mein maximaler puls 180 aber das habe ich ja schon easy überschritten
beim
Beim normalen rennen wo ich es mal drauf angelegt habe und insofern
Muss ein bisschen mehr sein den friseur gibt es noch 1 3 danke für den sub park
Du hast dein essen getrackt 850 kalorien ja gut das das ist jetzt nicht so schlimm
Ich meine du verbrauchst 2000 noch etwas am tag durchs pure existieren
Deswegen ist es ja auch so nice wenn man ab und zu mal sich ein bisschen bewegt und ihr müsst ja nicht so was machen wie
Gesagt ich hätte selbst nie gedacht dass ich mal anfange hier mit mit mit rennen ja
Ich mache das jetzt seit einem monat aber es macht mega bock und ich bin da echt konsequent mittlerweile jeden zweiten tag geht's raus
Das war wirklich anstrengend am anfang
den ersten
Die ersten runden gingen gar nicht richtig also als ich angefangen habe
mit rennen
Habe ich habe ich einmal geschafft in so einer normalen runde die ich normalerweise
laufe ja also mit laufen mal wirklich laufen nicht rennen laufen da habe ich dann mal insgesamt so
Drei mal ein bisschen über den kilometer zwischendurch eingestreut
Und ich habe gemerkt okay
Eigentlich geht es besser als gedacht das ist das was mich dann auch motiviert hat es mal wirklich wirklich auszuprobieren
Geht besser als gedacht aber ich hatte so
Extrem
Muskelkater leute ich habe eine normale runde gelaufen so 7,5 kilometer also genau wie gesagt nicht gerannt gelaufen und zwischendrin mal
Ja insgesamt
Auf drei etappen irgendwie so 3,5 kilometer gerannt davon und ich hatte die tage nach so
Extrem muskelkater alter ich konnte nicht richtig die treppe runterlaufen so habe ich dem oberschenkel gemerkt
So aber dadurch dass das ganz brauchbar ging hat mich das motiviert
Ein bisschen weiter zu machen und ein bisschen weiter zu machen und das längste was ich bisher am stück gelaufen bin sind 7,7 7,8
Kilometer allerdings natürlich deutlich langsamer
Die 7,8 kilometer habe ich gelaufen mit
7 7 minuten 50 pro kilometer und ich hatte am anfang probleme also anfang des monats ich mache das ja erst einen monat ja
Anfang des monats hatte ich noch probleme
auch nur kurze strecken unter 8
Und unter 8 minuten den kilometer zu rennen und was ich gemerkt habe ist und das hat mir der chat ja auch schon gesagt
was ich gemerkt habe ist
Mein puls ist ordentlich runtergegangen beim rennen also am anfang hatte ich das hier eigentlich
schon wenn ich keine ahnung
8 minuten 15 8 minuten 20 oder so gerannt bin pro kilometer hatte ich das hier schon mal komplett im arsch danach
und
Jetzt laufe ich locker so 7 minuten 50 pro kilometer mit 145
Also es geht als dass das also man merkt das extrem und wisst ihr was mich was was ich persönlich extrem nice finde
So viel konnte ich noch nie am stück rennen ich war früher relativ sportlich ich bin
Fahrrad gefahren ich bin sehr viel inlineskates gefahren das hat das macht ja heute keiner ist komplett out ja ich bin viel geschwommen
Aber rennen war nie so meins ja dementsprechend habe ich auch keinen vergleich
Zu meiner jugend wie viel ich da geschafft hätte ich kann mich noch daran erinnern dass ich ein paar mal im kreis
Gelaufen bin auf auf irgendeinem trainingsplatz ja aber ich kann mich nicht nicht so wirklich daran erinnern und ich würde tatsächlich sagen
Ich bin jetzt
So also ich bin jetzt mit fast 40 39 ja bin ich was das laufen angeht fitter als ich jemals gewesen bin
Also fitter als mit 20 oder 15 fitter insgesamt würde ich nicht sagen
Da war ich früher sicherlich sicherlich deutlich fitter noch
alles viel danke für den zapp aber
850 kalorien ist nicht wild guck mal also ich merke mir das immer so einmal rennen sind so ungefähr 500 kalorien
Also meine meine runde und in der geschwindigkeit 500 kalorien das so viel wie eine tafel schokolade ungefähr
Das ist ein riesen sprung an speed ja ich kann euch auch erklären wo das herkommt
Also nein ich kein doping oder so ich kann euch auch ganz ich kann euch auch erklären wo das herkommt
Ich laufe ja seit
Drei vier jahren schon regelmäßig allerdings ich renne nicht sondern ich laufe
So mit so mit stöckchen so über über berg und tal und sowas
Und ich bin es halt schon gewohnt gewesen jeden tag
Eineinhalb stunden bis zwei stunden zu laufen ich meine nicht rennen wie gesagt ich meine zügig zügig wandern laufen
Und ich glaube dass das ausdauertechnisch wirklich schon einiges gebracht hat
Aber das habe ich halt nie gemerkt und beim rennen haben wir schlicht und ergreifend
Jegliche jegliche übung und muskel gefehlt so und nachdem ich jetzt einen monat gerannt bin
Habe ich ein bisschen vielleicht muskel in waden und beinen gekriegt so dass ich die die ganz brauchbare ausdauer
Die ich durch das dreieinhalb jahre täglich wandern schon bekommen habe dass ich die jetzt auch ganz gut auf
Auf den weg bringen wisst ihr wie ich meine weil ganz ehrlich
ich glaube
dass das für von 0 auf 100 nicht so easy ist in einem monat ich habe da überhaupt keine ahnung von ich habe mich mit der
Theorie ja nicht beschäftigt aber ich habe ein paar ich habe ein paar
Beiträge mir angeguckt und ein paar
Posts gelesen und artikel da braucht manche leute brauchen ein halbes jahr dass sie fünf kilometer durch rennen können
Das konnte ich beim dritten anlauf quasi
Also beim ersten mal hatte ich ultra muskelkater musste zwei tage drei tage pause machen danach habe ich es mal probiert
Fünf kilometer durch zu rennen da hatte ich aber noch die alten schuhe
Und das war auch mega anstrengend
aber seit ich mir hier diese
Seitdem ich mir die hier gekauft habe muss ich sagen geht es deutlich angenehmer ich bin ja nicht der leichteste wie gesagt ich bin
174 und wiegt
Zwischen ja ich kann es euch nicht sagen zwischen weil es immer ganz entscheidend davon abhängt ich wiege zwischen 91 und 94
So im durchschnitt würde ich sagen zu den meisten zeiten eher sowas um
Ziemlich genau 93 also wenn ich mir mittags mittags wiege wenn ich was gefressen habe ist eher 93 wenn ich mich morgens nach dem
Aufwiegen nach dem aufstehen wiege ist es eher 92
und wenn ich ultra viel gefressen habe und auch eine hose an habe dann 94 und wenn ich
gerannt bin
Nach dem nach dem frühstücken und nagge ich mich auf die waage stelle dann ist es halt 91
So und deswegen habe ich mir halt
Hier so ein paar schuhe gekauft die ordentlich gefedert sind gefedert ist glaube ich das falsche wort die ordentlich gedämpft gedämpft ist glaube ich
dass das richtige wort die halt ordentlich gedämpft sind
und das ist
ultra angenehm versus meine normalen turnschuhe leute davor hatte ich ganz normale so ganz
0815 billige stinknormale turnschuhe die ich halt jeden tag an habe
und die gehen mit denen kann man auch rennen und mit denen ist vielleicht auch am anfang ein bisschen angenehmer weil es halt stabiler am fuß
ist aber gerade für mich der halt ein bisschen
bisschen schwerer auch ist macht das gedämpfte echt einen unglaublichen unterschied mir haben so krass die schienbeine weh getan
die nach den ersten paar runden die ich gerannt bin
habe ich jetzt immer noch aber viel viel
weniger also
wir tun immer noch ein bisschen die schienbeine weh da muss man muss man auch aufpassen aber es ist einfach ein bisschen
belastungsmäßig weil ich nicht gewöhnt bin aber die ersten runden alle in den nicht in den nicht
gedämpften schuhen ich ich habe das hat das hat weh getan während dem rennen teilweise schon
aber seit ich die schuhe habe ist alles gut so aber genug über meinen
genug exkurs über meine lauf abenteuer
mal gucken das ist aber ich muss jetzt eine sache muss ich noch mal sagen ja das ist ein weiterer punkt
der mich darin bestärkt
was ich was ich auch schon mal in einem video in einem video gesagt habe ich glaube ich glaube in dem hier weihnachten
in irgendeinem weihnacht
in irgendeinem weihnachtsvideo
also ich habe irgendwann mal ein weihnachtsvideo gemacht da habe ich das gleiche drin gesagt und zwar
man glaubt gar nicht
ich habe doch nicht so viele videos gemacht da wird man auf ihn glaubt gar nicht wie schnell man in
viel kürzerer zeit als man denkt
ganz brauchbar ganz gut in was werden kann
womit man selbst gar nicht gerechnet hat
das einzige was man machen muss ist irgendwann anfangen mit dem scheiß und ich weiß dass es am schwierigsten ist
sich zu überwinden mit irgendwas anzufangen
weil ich bin selbst nicht der große macher was sowas angeht
ok ich finde das video nicht keine ahnung
Ich bin selbst nicht der große macher was sowas angeht so mit irgendwelchen
unbekannten sachen einfach einfach so anfangen ja
aber
ihr habt es euch vielleicht schon bei anderen sachen gedacht das ist das was ich dann auch immer im kopf habe und warum ich mich
wahrscheinlich die letzten jahre über einfacher überwinden kann was zu machen als früher
und das ist
wahrscheinlich hatte das jeder von euch schon mal
Wenn ihr irgendwas dann doch mal gemacht habt und dann zurückblickt nach einem jahr oder einem halben jahr
Dann denkt ihr euch
Das läuft doch eigentlich ganz gut warum habe ich denn das nicht schon zwei jahre früher gemacht
gibt es zu leute das habt ihr euch bestimmt bei ganz vielen sachen schon gedacht so
warum habe ich eigentlich so lange gebraucht bis ich das gemacht habe hätte ich das mal zwei jahre früher gemacht und gerade wenn man
Den progress sieht den man bei manchen sachen macht innerhalb von einem halben jahr schon in innerhalb von ein paar monaten schon
Dann denken da und das von anderen sachen kennt dann denkt man sich ja warum habe ich die nicht vor zwei jahren schon angefangen
Wenn man sich überlegt wie gut man das sagt im halben jahr schon kann
Wie gut wäre man dann erst hätten wir schon vor zwei jahren angefangen
also diesen gedanken hat wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal irgendwie gehabt und
Ich glaube seitdem ich das selbst erst mal realisiert habe dass das öfters vorkommt als man denkt
Kann ich mich die letzten jahre auch einfacher dazu überwinden
Sachen zu machen die von denen ich eigentlich so objektiv weiß dass sie sinnvoll sind aber auf die ich überhaupt keinen bock habe
Es gibt natürlich auch sachen die ich immer noch nicht mache und immer verpenne so steuererklärung und solche geschichten und ich muss ja auch nur
Mal im steuerberater was schicken ich muss ja nicht mal selbst machen
Also es gibt genug viele leute ich verschleppe auch 80 prozent der sachen weil ich keinen bock drauf habe ja
Und prokrastiniere wie man das dann so schön nennt aber ich kann mich zumindest die letzten jahre über
Besser für einige sachen überwinden als früher noch vor vor zehn jahren hätte ich im leben nicht gesagt max
Probier doch mal aus ob du fünf kilometer rennen kannst ich will leben nicht im leben nicht
Er hat gesagt boah nee alter geh mir weg und heute diesmal habe ich mir gedacht weiß was probier es doch einfach mal aus
Vielleicht geht das ja besser als ich denke und es ging dann auch besser als ich denke und dann bam
Geht es jetzt eigentlich ganz gut
Also wie gesagt mein ziel aktuell ist dass ich es irgendwann mal schaffe
In näherer zukunft
Zehn kilometer rennen zu können unter 60 unter 60 minuten und so mega weit bin ich nicht meine bestzeit aktuell ist
Ja irgendwie irgendwie irgendwas 32 30 für fünf kilometer also das ist jetzt ist es nicht ultra weit weg
Und für das dass ich erst angefangen habe richtig ernsthaft jeden zweiten tag zu rennen ist es ist denke ich durchaus drin
Just lan dankeschön für den sap ja mal gucken ich habe im sommer angefangen ich bin mal gespannt
Wobei ich gehe nicht um acht laufen auch wenn das hier so aussieht ich gehe normalerweise schon um kurz nach sieben uhr laufen weil danach
Ist homeoffice
Ja, was kostet das noch gerade mal gucken was kostet denn sowas sorgen für das bisschen zeit was kostet
Garmin brustgurt was kosten sowas
Also ich gehe mal davon aus dass man auch einen von garmin braucht dass man die mit
Mit der garmin uhr koppeln kann das ist bestimmt wenn nur lock in deluxe
513 kalorien ist einmal big mac nee ich glaube ein big mac hat ein bisschen weniger oder
Big man hat immer noch unglaublich viel aber ich glaube ein big mac dürften ich würde ein big mac so auf 300 kalorien oder so
big mac
Ja habe ich doch ganz gut geschätzt
Was der brustgurt end plus fähig das gibt ja auch echt die bescheuerten standard bezeichnung oder es war aber auch echt anstrengend
Also das werde ich definitiv nicht freiwillig jeden tag rennen das war schon echt anstrengend
Nicht bis zum umfallen anstrengend aber anstrengend war ein marathon habe ich kein ziel jemals den marathon zu rennen
Wie gesagt mein ziel mein ziel in nächster zeit ist also in näherer zukunft
Ist 60 minuten und ein bisschen unter 60 minuten für zehn kilometer
bestimmt
Du klingst als seist du 30 leute vor zehn jahren wo ich 30 war
Haben die leute mir erzählt max du klingst wie 15
Die leute sagen immer wenn ich sag wie alt ich bin immer minus zehn jahre
Rgb schuhe das sind an streng erinnern park sehr gute reminder
Also noch kontakt zu solution wenn ich das gerade sehen dass er hier dass er hier strebt
Äußerst selten sehr selten wenn überhaupt es ist auch so
Also was ich bei mir jetzt gemerkt habe ist ich habe nach einem tag pause
wirklich richtig bock
Dann den anderen morgen rennen zu gehen
Also ich habe das gestern abend gemerkt gestern abend habe ich im bett gelegt und habe mir gedacht jawohl
morgen früh
sechs kilometer runde diesmal unter sieben minuten so nach dem motto und da habe ich heute mal vollgas gegeben aber sechs
36 ungefähr
Also kilo pro kilometer ach so falls das jemand interessiert dass man sich mal ungefähr
die
Kann ich vielleicht auch noch mal sagen dass man sich ungefähr die geschwindigkeit vorstellen kann die man dafür rennen muss
und jetzt und jetzt
Ich sage ich das gleich mal im vergleich
Es kommen andere tage bestimmt gerade wenn es kalt ist und regnet ja da haben wir auch keinen bock drauf also das ist
9,3 kilometer also 9,3 km h ist das so und jetzt passt mal auf
wisst ihr
dass das nicht mal halb so schnell ist
Nicht mal halb so schnell wie der marathon weltrekord
Und das über 40 oder 42 kilometer der marathon weltrekord liegt bei über 20 km h
und bei
ich glaube
45 oder so pro kilometer
Die die kerl die typen sind komplett abgedreht ala
Man muss sich man muss sich das mal vorstellen
Ich glaube ich glaube die nicht 320 die die rennt man kann sich doch relativ einfach ausrechnen marathon ist 42 ist aber ist 40 kilometer
und der rennt ungefähr mit 20 km h das heißt da braucht
Zwei stunden da kommt es ganz gut hin das ist der weltrekord müsst ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen
Ich renne volle pulle
Über sechs kilometer
Nicht mal halb so schnell
Wieder wieder marathon weltrekord hat er über 40 kilometer
Das ist schon heftig oder
Mega krasse dudes alter so
Und heute bin ich zum heute bin ich letzten paar hundert meter mal richtig richtig zackig gerannt das war
16,7 km h immer noch langsamer als der durchschnitt
Ja gut das sind meistens irgendwelche äthiopier und kenianer so ganz kleine ganz kleine dünne dünne hüpfer
Aber die haben aber auch stau oder und die rennen ja da auch schon seit sie da gibt es ja solche gibt es ja quasi solche
Nachwuchs förder camps
Die rennen ja da schon mit die fangen ja keine ahnung mit mit vier jahren oder so an zu rennen und rennen ihr ganzes leben
Aber die sind echt krass
Wie oft warst du jetzt schon joggen?
Naja seit seit auch seit anfang august jeden zweiten tag kann man sich ausrechnen wir sind im monat her also sagen wir mal
16 mal oder so jeden zweiten tag
irgendwie 15 16 mal
Der rüpel dankeschön 37 monat das ist ja hyper subscription hier
Ich habe ja auch ein bisschen übergewicht also ich weiß nicht wie
Okay sind wir sind wir was das übergewicht angeht mal etwas etwas positiver
Und nehmen das gewicht nach ich nach dem rennen okay
91 kilo
BMI rechner
Ja
Techniker krassen krasse die erzählen uns das jetzt bin ich zu dick okay jahre ich bin
Ich bin 39
Ich bin
Bis wie hin geht das
und ich wiege
90 kilo
Das ist der endpunkt
BMI rechner der hat es jetzt als webservice sie wiegen etwas leute okay ich wiege nur noch etwas zu viel okay immerhin
Geologie ist dankeschön für den satt ach so noch september ja dann let's go
Überweist ein bisschen gern besos das als welt anfliegen kann
Das ist bmi es ist service
Okay leicht erhöht leicht erhöht ist da erbärt das ist aber echt ganz gut ich hätte gedacht ich bin noch dicker
Weil ich komme immer noch relativ sagen wir mal
Ja
Ganz ganz gut dabei vor ja wenn ich mich im spiegel so angucke also da ist immer noch genug dran
Ich hätte gedacht der bmi ist höher
So und ich hatte mal ich hatte mal vor vor corona
hatte ich mal
108,5 109
Da war ich viel zu fett
Übergewicht
Das birgt die gefahr von krankheiten wie diabetes
Ja
habe ich auch glück gehabt
Vielleicht vielleicht bleibt mir das diabetes erspart dadurch dass ich mich jetzt ein bisschen mehr bewege
Ich müsste mal anfangen wieder ordentlich blutdruck zu messen
Weil die letzten male wo ich probe probe halber gemessen hat war es ein bisschen wenig
Ja ganz ehrlich das stört mich also sage ich jetzt ja sage ich jetzt das stört mich erst mal nicht
wenn ich wenn ich meine
Zehn kilometer unter einer stunde durchkriege schneller muss ich nicht sein also
das ist ich mache das hauptsächlich nicht um
der krasse
40 world record holder zu werden
Sondern weil ich den eindruck habe dass das für die gesundheit nicht schlecht ist
Und solange es bock macht ist ja noch besser
Ach big man ist noch mehr okay
Wir haben das video aufgenommen das war viel zu lang wir wollten es etwas kürzen und noch mal aufnehmen dazu ist es nie gekommen
Weil ich einen neuen job habe und der
Bekannte mit dem ich das aufnehmen wollte auch einen neuen job hat im influencer marketing bereich
Und da ist halt immer viel los
Ich also nicht wirklich falsch verstehen ich habe keinen job im influencer marketing bereich würde ich nie machen ihr wisst was ich von den
meisten influencer marketing leuten generell von marketing und
Werbeagentur leuten halte ich würde das nie machen ich könnte das wäre auch viel zu kacke für
Könnt ihr was programmieren ja aber dieses dumme geschwätz den ganzen tag nähe das halte ich nicht aus
Max was ich vorher noch fragen weil ich habe die fachhochschulreife allerdings ist mein mathe im zeugnis leider nicht so gut
Bin ich bin jemand der learning by doing am besten kann ich hoffe das stört nicht den fach von einem
ach das ist schwachsinn
Du brauchst kein mathe in der fachinformatiker ausbildung du brauchst auch kein deutsch
Also ich war in frankfurt an der berufsschule du kannst davon ausgehen der deutschanteil war nicht sonderlich hoch
Machst du auge walla
Oder wie auch immer also
Deutsch deutsch mag sein dass man ein paar sachen versteht aber noten in mathe sind schon mal wurscht brauchst du nicht
berufsschule ist lächerlich einfach wenn du fach abi hast
Ne du hast normales abi
Wenn du das ist der langweil zu wissen ich langweil in der berufsschule
Max es sprintet bald auf den mount everest ja so sieht es aus
Der weg zum fitnessinfluencer
Wobei wobei man sich den werdegang von dem kerl mal anguckt dann ist es ja vom fitnessinfluencer
eher zum comedygruppe scammer
pox subscription ja wie viel musst du noch abnehmen dass der bmi passt
Jetge ist der bmi kacke
Oder muss man die maus man muss die maus loslassen nicht reaktiv
Anzeige ist raus an den an den entwickler
So wie viel muss ich noch abnehmen
80 also okay leute ich müsste doch knapp über zehn kilo abnehmen
aber nee
Ja 82 also ich müsste ich sag mal ich müsste genau zehn kilo noch abnehmen dass ich dass ich wieder gutes gutes gewicht hätte
kritische sonntag gewicht 53 da da bin ich ja noch ein bisschen von weg
Also ganz ehrlich
zehn kilo noch mal
schon ordentlich
mein ziel ich habe ich habe ich gar kein abnehmen ziel mein ziel ist jetzt erst mal
zehn kilometer unter 60 minuten rennen
und ich gehe ich hoffe dass das abnehmen zumindest ein bisschen nebenbei halt auch geht
Ich meine es sind halt einfach am tag
Mal mindestens
plus
extra kalorien die man verbraucht oder sagen wir jeden zweiten tag aber meine normale laufrunde mache ich ja auch noch
Also ich war mit leute wisst ihr wo ich mega aktiv war
muss ich euch mal sagen ich war richtig aktiv
Also ich war wirklich mega aktiv also ich war wirklich mega aktiv
Leute wisst ihr wo ich mega aktiv war muss ich euch mal sagen ich war richtig aktiv und zwar
ist hier gar nicht ist hier gar nicht drauf
an einem tag war ich tatsächlich man kann es sich kaum vorstellen aber
Ach moment das ist noch das ist noch für august ist ja auch blödsinn was es da anzeigt hier
am samstag am samstag
war ich
6,1 kilometer rennen morgens
5,6 kilometer laufen also wirklich langsames laufen
direkt danach noch und nachmittags noch mal eineinhalb stunden 7,7 kilometer
das hat ordentlich das hat 570 kalorien
340 kalorien und
519 kalorien quickmaps das waren das waren ungefähr
Ungefähr 1200 kalorien zusätzlich am tag
Das war halt ein tag ja das war halt das war halt heftig ja also an dem tag habe ich auf jeden fall
auf jeden fall hätte ich auf jeden fall ein paar quickmaps essen können an dem tag
Ansonsten es sind halt 3 kalorien
Futterst du eigentlich bewusster
Ich futter bewusster mehr ja
Nee ich esse ich esse mehr oder weniger das gleiche wie die ganze zeit also
Ich esse nicht mehr ich esse nicht weniger das einzige was ich gemacht habe für das abnehmen
Ich habe ein minimal weniger fett gefuttert
Das aber gar nicht das ausschlaggebende punkt gewesen
Oh warte mal was mit meinem Headset los
Geht alles gut
Ja aber das bisschen weniger fett ist gar nicht der ausschlaggebende punkt gewesen
Oder vielleicht dass es ein bisschen gesünder ist oder so sondern dass ich halt mich bewegt habe
Hast du schon eine idee was du im winter machst habe auch letztes jahr angefangen zu joggen gut fortschritt gemacht, bin allerdings faul gewesen
Weiß ich nicht, ich mach das ja noch nicht so lang
man könnte es natürlich mal ein paar
Muckis sich antrainieren
dass man nicht nur ganz gute ausdauer hat sondern auch ordentlich ausschaut wieder
Wäre vielleicht auch nicht verkehrt
Da muss ja nicht gleich der next giga chat werden
noch ein video
Das habe ich sogar schon aufgemacht
100 gramm mehr gemüse in den tag zu integrieren
Ich weiß nicht
Okay, da lasst uns da lasst uns doch kommen wir gucken uns jetzt noch ein zwei videos an so wie ich mich kenne schaffen wir
Genau eins in 20 minuten
Das haben wir hier zu bieten, okay da ist es doch hier die neue wenn es in Mordgaard gepostet hat können wir uns das angucken
die neue und verrückte technik der IFA
Wusste gar nicht dass es die IFA jetzt nach Corona wieder gibt
Dann lasst uns das doch mal angucken welche neue verrückte technik da ist
Wahrscheinlich
Nichts was ich sparen, ihr kennt mich ich finde alles immer schlecht
Ich habe ja schon so den ruft ich finde ich finde alles immer schlecht so richtig boomer mäßig
Bis auf die sachen die ich gut finde aber die meisten sachen finde ich schlecht oder oder was heißt schlecht schlecht ist das falsche wort
Die meisten sachen finde ich nicht schlecht, sondern die meisten sachen finde ich oftmals so
Überflüssig und sinnlos
Mal gucken ob es jetzt anders ist
Hey leute ich stehe hier auf der IFA das ist europas größte technik messe hier wird viel spannendes zeug vorgestellt
Und ich ist immer noch in berlin da muss man nach berlin dafür fahren monkaS
Berliner hauptbahnhof
Ist wenn man frankfurt hauptbahnhof gewohnt ist gar nicht so schlimm
Wenn man es nicht gewohnt ist schon
Ja machen wir ein bisschen lauter
Es gibt wieder neue das ist ja seit ein paar jahren trend staubsauger, nicht staubsauger, rasenmäher
Staubsauger auch aber rasenmäher ohne draht zu verlegen ich stehe hier zwar gerade nicht vor dem neuen tesla aber heute wurden tatsächlich das neue
Tesla model 3 angekündigt es hat 50 prozent neue teile sieht insgesamt finde ich viel schicker aus viel aggressiver und sportlicher
Aerodynamischer ist es ruhiger geworden schicker krasses upgrade aber soll es nächstes jahr rauskommen wenn wir teslas zahlen vertrauen können
Vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen später
schon mit windows 11 angefreundet
Das ist windows 11
Auf der IFA sieht man eigentlich alle technikprodukte von allen technikherstellern und bei DJI gab es jede menge drohnen zu entdecken
Ja so ein teil
Da habe ich Mist getippt
So ein ding will ich mir auch schon seit einer weile kaufen ich kann mir bisher aber noch keinen einsatzzweck rechtfertigen
Ich brauche keine drohne aber ich hätte gerne eine drohne
Chat könnt ihr mir da irgendwas sagen wie ich mir das selbst erklären kann dass ich unbedingt mir eine drohne kaufen soll
Wenn am geld soll es nicht scheitern aber irgendwie den halbwegs zumindest vorgeschobenen plausiblen grund hätte ich gerne
Habt ihr irgendeine idee was ich mir sagen kann warum ich unbedingt eine drohne brauche
Ich wusste es chat ich wollte gerade sagen ich wollte gerade sagen
Jetzt erzählt mir nicht dass ich mir die nachbarn
Halbnackig im garten angucken kann oder so die will ich beide nicht halbnackig im garten sehen
Außerdem ist das mit sicherheit verboten
Um dein dach zu scannen
random leute abfacken
Das ist natürlich der beste kunde sich eine drohne zu kaufen und herrn max warum haben sie sich eine drohne gekauft random leute abfacken
dach scannen
Die idee finde ich gut die idee finde ich gut ich weiß bloß nicht nach was ich mein dach scannen soll
Nach was kennt man so ein dach
Mit
Lautsprecher das wäre geil
Lose ziegel
Solaranlagenplanung
Viren wie viren auf dem dach ja also wie gesagt die drohne hätte ich schon lange gerne
Die lautstärke ist doch gerade leiser geworden
So was immer zu sehen und man konnte sogar eine drohne in der messehalle fliegen
Ich stehe vorm neuen
2023 der frame von samsung und er ist jetzt noch etwas das sind die dinger die
Dünnen in dünner rahmen und und für die wand hängen aber ultra teuer war das nicht dass es irgendwie
22.000 euro oder so kostet moment
the frame
reis
okay
Dann habe ich was anderes im kopf was so mega teuer war
Man kann mit dem stk paar coole sachen an ja natürlich wenn ich eine drohne kaufe erst mal custom firma drauf oder
Durch einfach aussieht wie ein bild an der wand das ist wirklich krass und es gibt jetzt auch in riesigen
85 zoll was dann schon ziemlich großes bild an der wand ist ganz ehrlich
Das wäre für mich ziemlich nice
Weil ihr kennt ja vielleicht aus dem aus meinem video
Max fps wohnzimmer ich habe eigentlich ziemlich gute voraussetzungen dafür und zwar man sieht
Man sieht sich wirklich weil ich hier auf dem fernseher gesucht habe hier drumherum da ist nichts da ist einfach eine große
Also hier unten ist ein schrank aber außer dem schrank und dem fernseher ist nichts an der wand das ist einfach nur eine
Große relativ hohe weil die decke dort relativ hoh ist weiße wand
Also für mich im wohnzimmer
Würde sich prinzipiell so ein ding echt lohnen 85 zoll an die wand hängen
Also lohnen meine ich halt von der es wäre eine ein guter raum um sowas zu installieren
Für mich selbst lohnen würde sich nicht weil ich gucke so gut wie nie fernsehen
Alter was mit der musik los
Können wir uns darauf einigen dass die musik und die sprache in irgendeiner art und weise vielleicht gleich laut sein kann hier kann man das
Hier kann man das samsung flip 5 und fold 5 natürlich auch noch mal sehen und auch die samsung tablets und smart watches alles dinge die ich natürlich schon getestet habe aber
sind ja noch relativ neu
Ja so bei LG ist abgesehen von ein paar neuen kühlschränken und waschmaschinen nicht viel neues gehen wir weiter
Ja und diese gruselige maske soll ein weniger gruselig aussehen lassen sie sorgt dafür dass die haut weniger altert das gibt es aber auch
What
Eine maske mit rgb
Ein weniger gruselig aussehen lassen sie sorgt dafür dass die haut weniger altert es gibt verrückte dinge hier auf der ifa ich bin hier gerade am
Stand von honor und das ist vielleicht mein highlight von der ifa das ist das honor magic v2 das wurde zwar schon in china angekündigt aber
Jetzt ist auch in europa und das ist so so dünn dass ein faltbares smartphone
Leute ich muss glaube ich noch eine dritte aussprache in meinen wortschatz aufnehmen es sind nicht nur die china chinesen
Aber auch die chinesen chinesen chinesen chinesen chinesen chinesen chinesen chinesen chinesen chinesen
Die china chinesen das sind auch die china china china chinesen um genau zu sein
Gibt es noch irgendwelche betonungsmöglichkeiten von china
Was sich halt nicht mehr anfühlt wie ein faltbares smartphone das ist geschlossen 10 millimeter dick es wiegt weniger als ein iphone 14 pro max
Und aufgeklappt ist es halt nur 4,7
Millimeter dünn und hat trotzdem ein 5
Akku also ein riesengroßen akku ist eine ganz neue akkutechnologie
5000 milliampere stunden akku also ein riesengroßen akku ist eine ganz neue akkutechnologie
Und mit dem titan scharnier und allem und es ist wirklich unglaublich beeindruckend dieses riesige display
1600 nits hell vorne sogar
Ich muss sagen das ist ein klappt phone was ich irgendwo noch sinnig finde
Diese diese anderen klappt phones die so quasi die
In der mitte geklappt werden um dann normalen handy bildschirm von der größe zu haben die finde ich nicht sinnvoll
Aber das macht einen ganz coolen eindruck bei klappt phones leute ihr wisst ich bin 1984 geboren ich muss bei klappt phones
immer an diese möchte gern
Wie kann man das umschreiben
Möchte gern millionär handys denken von früher so kennt ja kennt bestimmt noch einer diese diese
Razer
Klappt handy in gold und sowas ja diese dinger ja diese teile
Diese diese möchte möchte gern millionär handys
Wo sich damals die leute so so wahnsinnig geil gefunden haben als sowas hatten
oder das gab es auch irgendwie deutsche wie schreibt man die deutsche und und
kakabana
Ja die die gab es damals auch und da gab es dann wirklich leute die mit diesem shit rumgelaufen sind und sie nicht
mega geil fanden weil sie so ein handy hatten
Das damals schon total dämlich
Aber klappt handys muss ich immer an diesen diesen ollen shit denken
von der nitz hell und hinten haben wir eine triple kamera
66 watt schnellladen es ist der traum eines nerds und auf jeden fall die zukunft von faltbaren smartphones
Dass man ihnen gar nicht mehr anmerkt dass sie faltbar sind
Es ist schon android oder schon eine weile in der hand und ich will es auch gar nicht in der hand legen
Weil es sich wirklich so beeindruckt und das hier ist ein konzept smartphone von honor das ist das magic v
purse sieht sehr ähnlich aus zu einem huawei smartphone was schon mal gehabt also auch ein faltbares smartphone man soll es halt
umhängen haben wie eine handtasche und sie hatten ja auch eine stelle ich mir auch anstrengend vor
die machen das die models die machen das den ganzen tag
Die laufen da
in die eine ecke
lachen in die kamera mit mit dem ding umgehängt laufen in die andere ecke das machen die acht stunden am tag
eine modenschau und alles
ja
witzige idee aber ich glaube nicht dass es so jemals auf den markt kommen wird wir sind bei fairphone und es wurde das fair von fünf
vorgestellt und das ist das faireste smartphone auf dem markt und auch das was man am besten reparieren kann ich kann die rückseite
einfach abnehmen und den akku in keiner art
Und das erging mir jetzt aber erstaunlich zu einfach
das was man am besten reparen die sind doch schon geöffnet oder
Ich will nicht blöd an mein smartphone hinten dran kommen und ist der deckel abieren kann ich kann dir die rückseite einfach abnehmen
und den
Es geht normalerweise bestimmt schwerer oder das haben die schon so gemacht dass es jetzt einfach auf geht zum testen akku in keiner art um
Fünf sekunden austauschen das richtig krass aber auch das update versprechen ist krass soll fünf jahre android updates geben
Aber immerhin acht bis zehn jahre lang sicherheitsupdates
Und bestimmt auch ordentlich custom firmware bei den dingern 30 was man sich ja gar nicht vorstellen kann also custom firmware irgendwelche android
Custom roms das hat vorne ein 6,5 zoll display mit 90 herz ist ein oled display das kann man ganz einfach reparieren die kameras
Kann man einfach reparieren da kann die anschlüsse einfach reparieren und alle rohstoffe wurden auch nachhaltig und fair gefördert
Also ich muss mich bei sowas immer zurückhalten und zwar also mit kaufen
Mein erster reflex ist ich finde das ist eigentlich eine richtig coole geschichte
Und da denkt man sich so ey weißt du was nettes smartphone
lange akkulaufzeit
faire herstellungsbedingungen
Das muss man supporten
Ich kaufe mir davon eins auch wenn ich eigentlich keins brauche ich will das supporten so nach dem motto ich habe mir das schon bei
Einigen dingern gedacht bei manchen dingern habe ich es auch gemacht das problem dabei ist nur du supportest
Es immer noch am besten indem du es einfach nicht kaufst wenn du es nicht brauchst
Das ist halt das ding es macht auch überhaupt keinen sinn wenn man jetzt irgend so ein uraltes
dreckschleuder auto hat
Egal was es für ein alles kack auto ist
Macht keinen sinn solange das noch ordentlich fährt und noch drei vier jahre hält sich jetzt ein elektroauto zu kaufen das macht einfach keinen sinn
Und natürlich kann man es also nicht wenn man das ich sage mal wenn man das rein aus umweltgesichtspunkten macht
Wenn man das macht weil man die technik cool findet
Let's go ja wenn man das macht weil man sagt hey ich habe keinen bock mehr auf meine alte scheiß kiste
Ich will was nur ist let's go aber so diese geschichte mit ich
Tue jetzt was gutes für die umwelt wenn man es wirklich gut ist für die umwelt tut dann ist es in der regel ich sage
nicht immer aber in der regel
Wahrscheinlich die beste entscheidung man benutzt das alte bis es auseinanderfällt
Das heißt es wäre wahrscheinlich auch eine blöde idee zu sagen ich brauche eigentlich kein fairphone oder kein android handy
aber ich kaufe mir das um das zu supporten so und
Das ist halt das ding
Genau richtig wenn man aktuell ein neues handy
Möchte oder vielleicht braucht weil es aktuelle den geist aufgibt dann kann man sagen okay ich finde das eine gute sache
Vom gerät her finde ich es auch gut ich gucke mir meinen fairphone an aber zu sagen so coole sache ich kaufe mir jetzt ein
Fairphone obwohl ich nicht brauche ist eigentlich bescheuert ist eigentlich keine mit geholfen
Außer der bilanz von fairphone natürlich
Das heißt hier wurde versucht das fährste smartphone zu machen das kommt natürlich mit ein paar kompromissen
Es hat ein bisschen sonderbaren prozessor der eigentlich aus smart home geräten ist solche smarten kühlschränken das heißt er ist nicht der stärkste
Und vielleicht nicht der effizienteste und der akku ist mit 4200 milliampere stunden auch nicht der größte
Und mit 699 euro ist das handy ja relativ teuer und es ist auch relativ dick und so
Aber das ist anscheinend der preis den man zahlen muss für ein faires smartphone ich finde cool dass sowas existiert ich finde es auch
Und ganz ehrlich wenn die wirklich so lange firmware updates liefern und dadurch dass das zusammen mal ein relativ offenes system ist
Gibt es dazu bestimmt auch ewig custom roms mich würde nicht wundern ich habe nicht nachgeguckt
Aber ich würde nicht wundern wenn es für das allererste fairphone wenn das jetzt ist was war das das 4 oder was hat er gesagt
Wahrscheinlich immer noch custom firmware geben würde
Trägst du deine smart smartwatch 24 7 nein war ich nicht ich schlafe nicht damit
Auch wenn die das immer anzeigt so nach dem motto ja an besten
Ergebnisse haben wir wenn sie das auch im schlaf tragen keinen bock
Ich ziehe die eigentlich nur an wenn ich wenn ich mich bewegen gehe es geht darum dass 700 euro teuer sind für das was man bekommt
Also gerade er findet das neue smart iphone
Mit dem was das doppelte kostet sicherlich extrem nice ich habe schon ein paar videos von ihm geguckt auf dem channel die finden
Diese die die apple sachen in der regel extrem nice
Auch sony hat ein neues smartphone gezeigt und es ist das ist das fairphone es ist das xperia 55
Ich meine war deutlich schlanker und kleiner
Das menü hier sieht übelst vom iphone gerippt aus oder
Vielleicht hat apple auch das von android geklaut das will ich mal offen lassen da klaut jeder von jedem als das fairphone es ist das
Xperia 55 ich meine natürlich 5 5 es ist ziemlich kompakt mit einem 6,1 zoll full hd plus oled display es hat natürlich
120 herz und für sony typisch ein
21 zu 9 format drin steckt der snapdragon 8 gen 2 also die neueste technik es hat einen riesigen 5000 milliampere stunden akku
Zwei kameras und die hauptkamera ist dieselbe wie die vom xperia 1 mark 5 die mir richtig gut gefallen hat und es hat sogar noch
Trommelwirbel bitte ein kopfhöreranschluss
Lenovo hat ein paar neue produkte gezeigt eines davon sind die legion glasses das ist eine brille die einen display vor dich
Das ist auch so ein ding diese produkte gibt es einfach um zu zeigen guckt mal her was wir geiles machen können
Ich glaube nicht dass der hersteller selbst damit rechnen dass sie sich gut verkaufen
Oder meint irgendjemand ernsthaft dass zum beispiel dyson wirklich meint dass sich
Dieses ding hier gut verkauft moment moment das beste kommt ja gleich noch
Meint ihr wirklich dass da ist denkt das verkauft sich gut
Übrigens was ich cool finde dass sie in der werbung
hauptsächlich fokus auf den kopfhörer legen und das eigentliche gimmick dieses visier mit mit luftfilter
gar nicht groß gar nicht groß zeigen
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass sie wirklich denken dass es irgendjemand
dass das der krasse verkaufsschlager wird
Naja
Beziehen kann aber mein highlight war das legion go das ist so was wie ein steam deck oder die rg ally nur dass man die
Kontrolle an den seiten abnehmen kann wie bei der nintendo switch
außerdem ist das ganze ding ganz schön groß weil es ein 8,8 zoll display hat da läuft windows drauf und
Von welchem hersteller war das jetzt leute ich habe ich habe es ich habe es verpasst
das so eine switch für arme
Lenovo Lenovo kaufe ich mir nie im leben mehr
Ich war großer thinkpad fan aber entertainment sachen von Lenovo never würde ich mir nie wieder kaufen was
Man kann sogar einen der controller als maus
Die sind meist im support einstellen für für solche geräte
Nutzen mit einem adapter der beiliegt angetrieben wird das ganze vom amd ryzen z1 extrem ich finde zwar cool dass Lenovo auch so ein produkt rausgebracht hat
Es fühlte sich nur leider ein bisschen
Auf der efe gibt es auch sehr viele kleine stände also einfach von marken von denen du im leben nichts gehört hast auf jeden fall
aber
noch gut sind keine ahnung ich hatte schon ein paar jahre kein neues mehr
interessant mal zu sehen was technisch so möglich ist was für verrückte ideen es gibt und was sich davon in der zukunft vielleicht durchsetzt und
Was auch nicht ich habe gerade was ganz verrücktes gesehen zwar face id aber für
die japanischen
Durchsetzt und was auch nicht ich habe gerade was ganz verrücktes gesehen zwar face id aber für hunde und katzen schnauzen
Wenn man das eigene tier verloren hat oder zum beispiel geklaut wurde kann man den schnauze scan über eine app
Und dann bekommt man die infos wem dieses tier gehört und das hat einfach dafür sorgen dass besitzer ihre tiere
Gute idee wird praktisch sich nicht durchsetzen weil es zu wenige kunden gibt und die basis zu kleines dann
An den usern zurückbekommen ja auch so was verrücktes sieht man auf der efa
Ziemlich witzige idee und es scheint zu funktionieren zumindest an diesen stofftieren die die vor Ort hatten
Wir sind hier gerade bei weddings und es gibt zwei neue hybride
weddings sind die mit dem
Mit dem urin scanner oder mit dem smarten urin scanner und leute wenn ihr jetzt denkt max
Was erzählst du dafür ein scheiß nein nein ich glaube das sind die wirklich
Ja genau smarter klo sensor
Da kriegst du dann zusammensetzungs
reports
über
Ihr hat ein urin
natürlich
cloud-basiert
obviously ja
Cloud-basiert selbstverständlich mein hätte irgendjemand an was andere was anderem gerechnet außer dass das cloud-basiert ist
Just gern die erste freihändige vernetzte urinanalyse für zu hause
bam
Ich würde interessieren wie gut sich das verkauft für mich persönlich wäre es nichts weil es wohl nur mit der
cloud lösung und der app vom hersteller gescheit funktioniert
Die scan watch light und das ist die scan watch 2 die light ist eine etwas günstigere kleinere version die kein
Ich
Jetzt muss ich jetzt muss ich aber mal was sagen ja das sieht hässlich
Esfakt aus dieses display auf der uhr oder
Als hätte einer dort ein aufkleber drauf gepappt der da nicht hingehört
Jetzt sagt man das sieht das sieht
mega billig und kacke aus
In watch 2 die light ist eine etwas günstigere kleinere version die kacke aus
Sauerstoff sensor die scan watch 2 hingegen hat alle diese sensoren und zusätzlich jetzt noch ein körpertemperatur
Sensor das ist richtig cool weil man jetzt eben auch in der app die körpertemperatur sehen kann das ganze wirkungs ökosystem ist ja sehr sehr
Groß das ding ist halt ganz ehrlich wenn ich so wenn ich so smart watch gedöhnt haben möchte
Dann kann das ruhig eine sein die die uhrzeit auch noch über display anzeigt das finde ich bei der gamme in ur tatsächlich ganz praktisch
Das ist das was
Also neben dem preis auch das was mir bei der apple watch nicht so gefällt ist einfach die akku laufzeit bei der apple watch die
Kriegst kriegst einen tag mit rum das war's
Vielleicht eineinhalb tage
Bei meiner gamme in ur die sieht natürlich nicht so stylisch aus wie die apple watch und die mag vielleicht
in manchen sachen auch nicht ganz so
super
Akkurat wie die apple watch sein
Aber die ist deutlich günstiger und hält bis zu einer woche
Im normalen einsatz also insofern finde ich nicht schlecht
Die sensoren und zusätzlich jetzt noch ein körpertemperatur sensor körpertemperatur
Das ich dass ich merke wenn ich fieber habe falls ich selbst nicht merke oder wie das ist fast so
Erinnert sich noch einer dran an die präsentation von der apple watch
Wo sie wo sie dieses beispiel hatten
schwangere frau
mit apple watch
Und die apple watch sagt ihr dass sie jetzt ins krankenhaus muss weil das kind auf die welt kommt weil das hätte ich selbst ja
nicht gemerkt
Das ist ohne apple watch hätte ich es verpasst wahrscheinlich einfach
Das ist richtig cool weil ich auch in der app die körpertemperatur sehen kann das ganze wirkungs ökosystem ist ja sehr sehr groß
Sie haben ja auch wagen und schlafmatten und blutdruck messgeräte
Und jetzt gibt es eben die scan watch 2 die zusätzlich noch die temperatur messen kann sie startet bei
349 euro hat ein bisschen ein geändertes design ein schöneres display aber immer noch gehört das kind jetzt apple
das hat so eine imac farbe dann
30 tage akkulaufzeit ich persönlich trage jeden tag eine scan watch ich bin also sehr sehr happy dass es jetzt ein nachfolger gibt
Und bin gespannt die zu testen ein review wird selbstverständlich auf meinem kanal geben also
Abonniert ihn gerne um das nicht zu verpassen und ich habe gerade noch entdeckt bei willings gibt es auch diesen sensor in der toilette
sage ich doch smarter urin sensor auf dem man drauf winkeln kann der dann das urin
auswertet und einem daten über die gesundheit geben kann ich durfte ihn jetzt leider nicht ausprobieren aber
Spuck doch mal drauf
Und mal gucken ob das ding irgendwas anzeigt bin gespannt
Heute dazu ein review wir haben heute jede menge saugroboter gesehen aber ich wollte eigentlich nur einen sehen und das ist der neue
dreamy l
20s ultra
dreamy finde ich nice weil
ist auch
robocop am start
Dreamy finde ich nice weil dreamy noch custom firmware flashbar ist zum größten teil
Roborock teilweise aber das meiste nicht
Das meiste nur mit
Disassembly vom gerät und das fällt halt da habe ich keinen bock drauf kriege ich nie wieder zusammen
Diese station ist einfach riesig aber sie hat frischwasser sie hat schmutzwasser sie hat
reinigungsmittel und
Vereint das alles außerdem wird der mob da drin ist halt hin zwei rotierende mobs nicht nur gewaschen und trocken geföhnt
Sondern er kann wenn er teppich erkennt den mob auch in der station ablegen und sich dann selbst wiederholen
Für glatte bögen außerdem erkennt er wie dreckig ein boden ist und wenn er sehr dreckig ist wird er auch zweimal drüber gehen
Außerdem kann der mob auf teppich auch sich anheben etwa ein zentimeter hoch das ist krass viel früher ging eigentlich nur so ein halber zentimeter
Und der mob kann sich ausfahren um in ecken reinzukommen
Als wirklich krass das ist tatsächlich mal eine coole funktion
Wenn man wer drauf legt legt das auch alle ecken sauber werden das ist tatsächlich ganz nice
Aber ganz davon abgesehen
Bei mir ist überall fast überall teppich und ich hatte mal einen saugroboter der hatte auch eine wischfunktion die habe ich nicht einmal benutzt
mittlerweile
Bin ich auch als smart home fan ist ich habe da viel gemacht
Bei mir daheim und auf ihn selbst gebaut
und seit jahren schon ziemlich interessiert was smart home angeht aber
Ich habe meine staubsauger roboter wieder abgeschafft ich hatte mal zwei stück so einen ganz billigen
Und einen roborock
S55
Customfirma damals drauf ich beide wieder abgeschafft die dinger sind jetzt mittlerweile auf dem stand wo ich sagen würde ich überlege es mir noch mal
Seitdem die mehr oder weniger alle
premium serien eine eigene absaugstation haben
Das ist das was mich am meisten daran genervt hat aber ansonsten
Eigentlich brauche ich es nicht
Ich
also
Wenn staubig ist
Kann man hier auch mit dem stabs mit dem staubsauger schnell mal durch rennen und mit dem staubsauger geht halt so viel schneller
Als mit dem staubsauger roboter der staubsauger roboter braucht keine fett minuten oder so
Bis der hier und dann dann ist die batterie und dann kann er dann mal alles machen mit dem staubsauger
Blitzt du hier durch nur schlaf schlafzimmer geht schon mal gar nicht mit dem ging mit dem staubsauger roboter nicht nicht gut
Flur schlafzimmer arbeitszimmer wohnzimmer das ist in weiß ich zehn minuten ist das fertig
Dann musst du noch manuell wischen
Ich wische gar nicht man kann das wischen auch einfach lassen
Und einfach nur saugen wischen kann meine mutter machen muss ich nicht selbst machen
Das war ich den vorgänger schon technisch sehr beeindruckend fand aber diese version hier kann auch mal so viel mehr
Das ding ist riesig wie ihr sehen könnt das so schon nachteil aber immerhin ist diese station sehr sehr schön
Und ja der roboter hat natürlich die ganzen standard features also er ist sehr intelligent in der navigation
und er hat
7000 pascal saugleistung das auch ordentlich also das ist gerade so der modernste
Saugroboter man kann in der zwischenzeit rausgehen und zum sport na gut aber zehn minuten stört das doch nicht wirklich und zwar mit ordentlichem
Abstand und bei switchboard ist noch mal ein ganz anderer saugroboter der kann 250 milliliter wasser fassen
Und kann dieses wasser von seiner aus das habe ich gesehen das habe ich schon in einem anderen video gesehen
der switchboard hat drei verschiedene stationen er hat irgendwie eine
Eine wasserstation absaugstation und dann kann er das wasser irgendwie zu einer anderen station rüberfahren und so ganz
Transportieren zu einem raum befeuchter das heißt der roboter befüllt andere geräte im haushalt mit wasser
Fand ich eine ganz coole idee das waren meine ifa highlights für zwei tage lang über die messe gelaufen es war ein bisschen
Anstrengend aber hat auch sehr viel spaß gemacht dank an jeden einzelnen von euch der vorbeigekommen ist um hi zu sagen hat mich sehr
Na so viele geile sachen waren jetzt auf der ifa aber nicht oder hat mich jetzt nix so richtig geschockt
Für das video haben wir es nicht genug zeit
Ja was ich witzig fand heute hat mir youtube drei das sind die hier die habe ich mal aufgemacht drei physik videos
empfohlen
Eins davon von hermes
Das gucken wir uns das nächste mal an wie die physik ausbildung bei hermes so ist ob die besser sind als bei der bahn
Okay, leute 22 10 morgen muss ich arbeiten bett geteilt
müde schlafen
Die shorts empfehlung man
Das kannst du als kell doch kaum übersehen
Ich klicke aber nicht drauf weil umso mehr du da drauf klickst umso mehr dieser videos klickst du angezeigt
Und ich will irgendwas interessantes an kontent gehen kontent sehen und nicht einfach nur kontent
Sehen weil man da halt hingucken muss irgendwie
Leute wir sehen uns bis dann macht's gut